- [Narrator] Land-based
ballistic missiles,
submarine-launched weaponry
and bombs that can be
deployed from aircraft.
These are some of the weapons
in Russia's vast nuclear arsenal,
seen here on display in training drills
before Russia launched
its invasion of Ukraine.
- The strategic systems,
they have intercontinental range.
And so they can hit anywhere on the globe.
- [Narrator] While the US
doesn't communicate much
on its nuclear weapons,
Russia has been showcasing its advances.
(waves crashing)
(reporter speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] After President Putin ordered
Moscow's nuclear deterrence forces
to be put on alert in later February,
the Pentagon said it had not detected
any major new developments on that front.
Many analysts say it's
unlikely the weapons
will be used in warfare,
although it can't be ruled out.
But Moscow could use its
arsenal as a deterrent
to discourage the US and its allies
from taking more action
in the Ukraine war.
So here's what we know about
Russia's nuclear inventory,
the largest in the world
and Putin's push to modernize it.
When it comes to scale,
Russia and the US have a similar
number of nuclear weapons.
According to an estimate by the Federation
of American Scientists,
Russia's warhead inventory totals 5,977.
In comparison, the US has 5,428.
Those numbers are similar also due
to international arms control agreements
to limit the size of each
country's nuclear stockpile.
At the heart of Moscow's arsenal
is what military experts
call the nuclear triad.
The US also has nuclear triad status,
while China has been working
to achieve the same advanced
version in recent years.
In principle, Russia's weapons
can be delivered by air
with strategic bombers,
such as the TU-95MS
and TU-160 by its navy
with nuclear-powered
ballistic missile submarines
and by land-based ballistic launchers,
such as this RS-24 YARS.
The explosive force of atomic bombs
is measured in kilotons
and warheads on these weapons have a power
of as much as 400 kilotons according
to defense analysts.
That's more than 25 times
the atomic bomb the US used
in Hiroshima, Japan at
the end of World War II.
(pensive music)
Days after the first bomb was released,
another was dropped on Nagasaki,
seen here in this footage in 1945.
It became the last atomic
bomb to be used in combat.
Since then, countries
have built up arsenals
as a deterrent for conflict.
The US and Russia created
their vast stockpiles
during the Cold War.
- And our restraint is not inexhaustible.
- [Narrator] More recently,
and decades after the end
of that Cold War, Moscow is again touting
that its intercontinental
ballistic missiles
are capable of hitting the
US in 20 to 30 minutes.
Hans Kristensen is the director
of the Nuclear Information Project
and has been studying
nuclear weapons for decades.
He says long-range missiles
are the most powerful
elements in Russia's arsenal.
- And if that was released,
it could destroy all major cities.
- [Narrator] The US also
has missiles capable
of potentially hitting Russia
within a similar timeframe.
In addition, both
countries have stockpiles
of non-strategic nuclear weapons,
which are usually defined as
shorter-range delivery systems
with lower-yield warheads.
But analysts note as the
US has been scaling back
its stockpile of these weapons
over the last three decades,
Russia has largely kept its inventory.
- We think the US has
only a small inventory
of a few hundred tactical
nuclear bombs that are left.
This has been an important development
in the US arsenal evolution
because they used to have, like Russia,
a huge inventory of non-strategic
but they've largely moved away from that
in the US planning.
- [Narrator] Russia is modernizing
some Soviet era weapons,
which analysts say is a routine step
in order to maintain the
readiness of older tools.
It's also developing newer weapons
that have been publicized
by Russian President Vladimir Putin
and on Russian state TV.
(report speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Zircon is
one of six nuclear weapons
Putin revealed the country
was developing in March 2018.
Others included underwater
nuclear-powered uncrewed vehicles
and nuclear-powered global
range cruise missiles.
Analysts say it's hard to determine
what stage of development
they are currently at.
(whooshing sound)
Unlike the US,
Russia has been sharing
its nuclear capabilities
on state TV and online media.
Wary of stoking tensions
as war rages in Ukraine,
US officials even canceled
a scheduled weapon test.
Although other exercises continued.
In mid-March, the US Air
Force conducted drilled
with B-52 bombers,
capable of carrying nuclear missiles.
But to use nuclear weapons
would be a significant step.
Some experts say Putin may
turn to non-strategic bombs
if cornered in this war.
However, the bar is high
for any potential deployment
and it's unlikely that
Russia will use them at all.
- It's one thing to rattle the sword
and warn your adversaries
that you have this capability
by doing exercises or increasing alert
or something like that.
It's another step to
actually use nuclear weapons
because once you do,
all bets are off in terms of
how destructive this new phase
is going to be.
- [Narrator] The buildup and
showcasing of new weapons
during the Ukraine war reminds
some of the Cold War era,
a period when the US and
Russia used ownership
of nuclear forces as a defense
amid heightened tensions.
(pensive music)